The length of the rectangle is 12 units long and the width is 9 units. Great
work if you found these two numbers. The key to this problem is that the
diagonal is 15 inches long. The diagonal rectangle cuts from one corner to an
opposite corner. So, we can draw in this line and consider this to be one of
the diagonals. This line would be the other diagonal. But we only need 1
triangle in order to figure out the side links of our rectangle. We know the
diagonal is 15 inches long so we can label this with 15. We'll let the width of
the rectangle be x. Since we know the length is 3 inches longer than the width.
This means that the length must be x plus 3. Here again is another. We're using
algebra to relate two things. We have one unknown which is the width, and
relating to the length. Since the length is three inches longer than the width.
Now we have a right triangle and we're ready to use the pythagoreum theorem to
solve for x. Whole squared e to the legs which is this side and this side and
we know if we sum those squares together we'll get the squared hypotenuse or 15
squared. We'll combine these like terms together to get 2x squared plus 6x plus
9 equals 225. Next we'll subtract 225 from those sides so I have this quadratic
expression said equal to 0. These terms are all even, so we can divide our
equation through by 2. This gives us x squared plus 3 x minus 108 equals 0. We
find factors of negative 108 that sum to positive 3. Those factors are negative
9 and positive 12. So, we can write these two factors and then set each one
equal to 0 to solve for x. So, X can equal positive nine, or X can equal
negative 12. A negative side length wouldn't make sense in this case, so we'll
let X equal 9 here. So, if the width is 9, then we know that the length must be
3 more than the width, or, this would be 12 units. Again, great algebra
thinking if you got these two numbers.